N
UNIDENTIFIED AERIAL PHENOMENON.
IN JUNE THERE WILL BE A REPORT
TO CONGRESS ON UFOs THANKS TO A
LITTLE KNOWN STIPULATION IN THE
2020 COVID STIMULUS BILL SIGNED
BY FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD JCHD
TRUMP.
GUIDON LOUIS KRAUSE IS A STAFF
WRITER FOR THE NEW YORKER, WITH
A PIECE OUT ABOUT HOW THE
PENTAGON STARTED TAKING UFOs
SERIOUSLY.
HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN THE PENTAGON
SHARING THIS, LETTING EVERYONE
KNOW WHAT THEY'VE GOT AND WHAT
THEY'RE THINKING?
>> THAT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION.
THERE ARE PROBABLY A LOT OF
DIFFERENT ANSWERS TO THAT.
THE SIMPLEST ANSWER IS PROBABLY
THAT THE GOVERNMENT HAS ALWAYS
HAD PEOPLE INTEREST IN UFOs AS A
PHENOMENON EITHER IN HOBBYIST
CAPACITY OR BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT
THERE WERE POTENTIAL NATIONAL
SECURITY IMPLICATIONS AND IN
THIS CASE WHAT HAPPENED IS THAT
SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE BACK IN
2007 INTERSECTED WITH HARRY REID
WHEN HE WAS THE SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER AND HE AND THE LATE
SENATOR STEVENS AND INOWE GOT
TOGETHER TO HAVE AN OUTSIDE
CONTRACTOR STUDY AND WHAT WAS A
REALLY SMALL EARMARK, A ROUNDING
ERROR IN THE DEFENSE BUDGET BACK
THEN EVENTUALLY CAUGHT THE EYE
OF A REPORTER WHO HAD DONE WORK
FOR A NUMBER OF PUBLICATIONS
OVER 20 YEARS, ABOUT UFO
PHENOMENON.
SHE BROUGHT IT TO THE NEW YORK
SOMETIMES AND WITH A TEAM OF
OTHER REPORTERS WROTE THIS STORY
IN DECEMBER 2017, WHICH BECAME
CULTURAL INFLECTION POINT.
>> WOW.
>> MY REPORTING SEEMS TO HAVE
UNCOVERED THAT, BASICALLY,
WIDESPREAD FASCINATION WITH THE
IDEA THAT THE GOVERNMENT WAS
INTERESTED IN UFOs PROMPTED THE
GOVERNMENT TO BECOME MORE
SERIOUSLY INTERESTED IN UFOs.
>> SO GIDEON, I CAN'T KEEP MY
EYES OFF OF THE VIDEO.
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING WHEN YOU
SAW THESE IMAGES FOR THE FIRST
TIME?
>> WELL, THE VIDEOS ARE SORT OF
HARD TO PARSE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE MADE PRETTY PERSUASIVE
ARGUMENTS THAT WHAT IS BEING
SEEN ARE BALLOONS, PLANES OR
DRONES OR OTHER MUNDANE
TERRESTRIAL PHENOMENON.
IT'S HARD TO EVALUATE THEM
OUTSIDE A LOT OF ADDITIONAL
EVIDENCE THAT PEOPLE AT THE
GOVERNMENT CLAIM TO HAVE,
CLASSIFIED EVIDENCE FROM CENSOR
DATA, SATELLITE DATA.
SO IT'S REALLY HARD TO SAY
ANYTHING ALL THAT DEFINITIVE
BASED ON THESE VIDEOS ALONE.
>> I DON'T KNOW, THOSE LITTLE
THINGS DROPPING DOWN TO THE
OCEAN.
OKAY, WELL, I WANT YOU TO LISTEN
TO WHAT THE FORMER HEAD OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE HAD TO SAY
ABOUT UFOs RECENTLY.
>> THERE ARE A LOT MORE
SIGHTINGS THAN HAVE BEEN MADE
PUBLIC.
SOME OF THOSE HAVE BEEN
DECLASSIFIED.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT SIGHTINGS,
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OBJECTS THAT
HAVE BEEN SEEN BY NAVY OR AIR
FORCE PILOTS OR HAVE BEEN PICKED
UP BY SATELLITE IMAGERY, THAT
FRANKLY ENGAGE IN ACTIONS THAT
ARE DIFFICULT TO EXPLAIN.
>> SO WHAT CAN WE EXPECT FROM
THIS FEDERAL REPORT ON UFOs NOW?
I SAW YOUR EXPRESSION.
SHOULD THE PUBLIC EXPECT
CONFIRMATION OF UFOs OR
ADMISSION FROM THE GOVERNMENT?
WHAT'S POTENTIALLY NEXT HERE?
>> WELL, I MEAN CERTAINLY
THERE'S A BIG BASIC QUESTION OF
WHAT EVEN ARE UFOs AND OF COURSE
THE GOVERNMENT LOOKS AT IT SFRA
STRICT DIAGNOSTIC POSITION,
THESE ARE UNIDENTIFIED THINGS IN
OUR AIR SPACE.
WHAT EVERYONE HAS TOLD ME IS
THAT WE REALLY SHOULDN'T EXPECT
ALL THAT MUCH FROM THIS REPORT.
CERTAINLY IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
ANY EVIDENCE THAT WE'VE BEEN IN
TOUCH WITH SOME GALACTIC
COMMITTEE FOR DECADES.
IT'S POSSIBLE.
THERE'S ALMOST CERTAINLY GOING
TO BE A CLASSIFIED ANNEX OF THIS
REPORT THAT MIGHT CONTAIN
INFORMATION.
WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT THE
COMMENTS FROM FORMER DIRECTOR
RAD CLIFF IS I HAD HEARD THROUGH
ANY SOURCES THERE ARE PEOPLE IN
THE NRO UNHAPPY WITH THE FACT
THAT HE WENT ON FOX NEWS AND
TALKED ABOUT THINGS LIKE
SATELLITE DATA, THAT, YOU KNOW,
A LOT OF THOSE METHODS ARE
PROTECTED FOR GOOD NAT